hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the things in the
night for carrying right along that was
a good look upon that
grandfather clock for a second there but
we're carrying right along from the last
episode I don't know what's going on my
sanity is not doing all hey the picture
changed oh oh oh it's so creepy oh ah
y'all stare at it for a thing oh it's so
creepy okay I don't know what the deal
is I don't know what's going on I got
really confused I better take one before
I fall down oh wait I was already going
okay what is this what is this what is
this
greed will make you lose your head and
mind
what oh my god what what is happening oh
oh oh the controls are all oh my oh oh
holy crap go reach between this guy's
legs Oh Oh got it
huh what how does even possible how does
he even do this guy who made this if
you're still watching how do you how do
you do this oh I see you I see you there
oh man oh don't tell me what no huh
holy crap this is the most incredible
I don't even this this guy's an evil
genius genius amnesia should hire this
guy this goes beyond just simple custom
story and modding this is his level
design flex amiga frictional Studios
Chinese amount of care hire this guy
this guy's incredible anyway I got plug
number one which is for the electro wave
just number one and then I'm supposed to
find three things for the things oh man
there's so much more to this than I knew
I'm still tripping out with them
controls I still I'm trying to the old
service Aryan study oh oh
I'm trait all right everybody fire this
guy he's misspelled that I'm tricked and
I need to find the three keys to shut
down the electro waves oh this is a good
sign body parts everywhere
of course oh sure yeah why not you have
the rest
[Music]
oh he's a genius
listen evil genius I'm tougher than this
bring on
[Music]
just here so that anything that comes by
won't see me yeah yeah I'm tougher than
this guys you know me we're trying out a
new type of machine but I think it's
just junk and it's going to get someone
killed the machine runs on some new and
highly flammable chemical called Cornell
the good news is we're closing down but
the bad news is we have to take it apart
Cornell so I think I need to get
something called Cornell well anything
under there
No okay all right
yeah I'm I'm tougher than this
I'm not a big bubble blowing baby I'm a
man that come from where did I go where
did I come from cotton-eye Joe did I
meet my my door okay okay bring it on
Hey look dead people huh conspicuously
laid out dead people with tribal
Wow
why I can be
[Applause]
no-no-no I see ya see ya you're not
coming down here not here oh you're
coming down here
a what are you so ugly good thing I got
these convenient closets with which to
hide in I'm going to leave the door open
come at me bro you're my bro my bro is
10 times the bro that you are where is
it hey right there didn't see me it's
like in this shadow thing always banging
on a door I see think I'm in that door
what do big [ __ ]
you just ruined that door for nothing
serves you right
maybe I'm supposed to sneak past him
I don't know
I'll confuse I can't even see anything
through the fog there and the darkness
yeah sorry guys in this episode it's
really dark it's
I like it oh wait you vanished hey yay
so that guy can use doors cuz he just
disappeared out the door I came yay okay
now came from here man these rooms have
so far been just full of nothing looking
I'm looking messy no and I'm being very
careful very very careful about my
lantern oil I know I'm like sitting in
the dark the whole time but I've he's
not giving me anything
he's like giving me nothing oh wait
here's he hears him giving me something
I shouldn't talk out my [ __ ] Hey look
a dead guy what a surprise
the end of the road is wait ah some
secret why is it sealed off I need to
find a way to get it open
okay so this is some sort of lab or
kitchen so maybe there's something in
here that I can use
okay seems interesting but once again
nothing here so what am I supposed to do
huh confusion I mean there had to be a
cat like these again no I cannot there
had to be a point for coming down here
right I've been in each of these rooms I
didn't see anything what's the deal okay
whatever then
[Music]
this was locked
nope okay
hmm somehow need to get in that room
first so maybe there's a key really well
hidden somewhere I wouldn't be surprised
I swear the guy who made this like
master of he does not like to make
things obvious I mean he spells out most
of things you're supposed to do in the
notes but when it comes actually doing
what he tells you to do man it's not
obvious and then he may be by the desk
here new new new over here new professor
that out noop noop okay yeah no okay all
right I guess there's nothing else here
I'll go somewhere else I guess good I
can actually get out of there I've
worried that it was just gonna cut me
off so I literally need three of these
rod things
for some reason I got myself trapped in
here or I don't know what it's kind of
strange love low framerate no framerate
why
well that's the dealio what's going on I
get my frames back no okay all right
oh wait like yeah I totally trap myself
down so what's the deal I gotta like
find the key that I don't know about her
some chemicals that I'm not getting I'm
not with it my moves aren't slick enough
yo it's not happening I used to be with
it but then they changed what it was and
then it was strange to me I didn't get
it
I'm totally butchering that quote but if
any of you know what I'm talking
to us way too much Simpsons so here
something going on with yeah these
douches
Sacco you
it can cause death okay stick in that
hole junk
wait I did it didn't I I did it why is
it still up testing its fake you think
okay
Terminal two I still need more thingies
man oh man there's like threw me for a
loop really sending me out okay I'm
assumed the key to that area is in that
area so I happen
I should really dedicate myself to
searching around there but it seems like
it seems like some of the mannequins are
on my side I'll trust that for a second
of course but
okay so the what I'm looking for must be
over here somewhere I'm just not
I must have overlooked it or something I
need to find this chemical called
Cornell and how big was this castle is
gigantic
it's got weird electrical things I I
don't even know okay so there wasn't
anything over here by these chests or
closets anything in the piles it would
really help if I was able to see nothing
in here there was nothing under the bed
check that maybe one of the other beds
but all the other beds were like just a
hollow empty was this what's going on
there
I don't have enough oil for this but i
just-i can't-- you know search without
looking for can't see anything
what's with these guys what's with these
guys it's gotta be something right
anyway
I'm actually out of time so I'm gonna
think he think think on this puzzle and
get back to you guys so thank you all so
much for watching and as always see you
bye bye